Randolph Justin you guys been playing a
lot of Pokemon go and now I want to
transition and talk about your personal
stories your successes and all the
really weird crap that has happened
around this because not only is because
the side effect of this being a
phenomenon is I you know we're seeing
people you know having bizarre
experiences having great bonding
experiences putting themselves in danger
and all sorts of weird crap so let's get
into it first off I want to start by
letting you guys brag a little bit who
is your best Pokemon what was your best
catch okay let's hear it see I'm not
crazy because there was a bug as well
which I couldn't log into my Pokemon
tray in a club account and I had to
start giving my google account but right
now what do i have i've got a is really
embarrassing one tell me your best gold
dad is my best right now with a CP of
538 and i'm patiently trying to level up
some others what about you Justin I have
a pincer yes 273 okay see I thought I
was bad so a Randy would crush you in a
pokey right right now is that what I'm
reading yeah probably I like a Grimer I
just found that was kind of interesting
okay driverless is basically a pile of
throw-up that's he resided in a pile of
throw-up where did you find your thrill
of oh it was off to the side of a toilet
mmm somebody pissed all right yeah so
let's talk about the places you found
these islets hold like like literally in
a in a residence it will just show up
because there are also places like parks
and rivers and stuff that there's like
some of them are tied to landmarks as
well yeah correct so first up I think
some of the craziest stories that people
are reading out there have actually
proven to be false yeah right so so like
the the guy playing pokemon go while
driving causing a 30 car pileup I think
it was just horribly people's was a dead
body one eventually proven to be false
no that was true I mean it the dead body
wanted to clarify a woman was playing
pokemon go and she like hopped a fence
to like go be down by the river where
there would be more water-type pokemon
do they link it to natural it is they do
like if you're near water you'll see
more than she was looking through the
augmented reality screen and then
sly cognizant weird floating the water
over there dead guy okay so everybody
does it to be fair that's just a really
weird thing like that is a Pokemon yes
but people being dying you have to use
common sense with this it is still an
app you're not gonna you wouldn't walk
down the street reading your email
intently like some literally like that I
I have accidentally a couple zones is
really bad like like step out on the
road looking at my phone because
something had popped up and you know I'm
sort of like half aware that okay the
lights the lights okay now I can go many
other people are going i'm not actually
paying attention right i'm sort of
halfway across Iran you know I should
really look after my business right now
and just ignore this century that just
popped up until at least I get to the
curb and then and then I go but and then
stop and don't just stop in front of
other people like Eric yeah let's rip
off to the side actually this morning
was kind of weird because the best place
to play pokemon go is on public
transport or in a slow-moving car right
because that you get a lot of because
you're moving and not when you're
driving when you're driving of course
clarify yeah I know but when you're when
you're in a vehicle and you're going
through a lot of air is a lot more
pokemon pop up right and as long as
you're not going crazy fast you're not
doing 80 miles per hour down a highway
it's actually like a great way to like
quickly rack up Pokemon right so I do
this on a bus all the time and this
morning on the bus I was there and you
know I think it was a stupid zoo bad or
something popped up and i was sort of
doing this and i realized that the AI
was right in this woman's crotch oh oh
sorry guy okay um don't think i'm a
creeper why do you have to keep pointing
it here why do you have the camera on
when I'm in public transit I turned the
camera off so I don't look like a weird
creeper looks cool I'm on she's got a
zoo bet on her face imagine a zoo bandar
sounds like I to do that excuse me sir
no but laughs I kind of subtle man I
could just be reading right like oh
there's your crotch hahaha I'm doing
this yes he's like I know if you're a
subtle as you think y'all I'm very
nonchalant like I was another camera
Chris I just said sheriff's because I
having sex it doesn't mean you have
improved about but no but otherwise you
know i am responsible and i hate to say
this but there will be
there will be an injury or two because
of this game the question is will
somebody self-report an injury knowing
that they will be up on reddit before
the half hour as I and I I think it's
more the type of people that would say
oh because of Pokemon go this happened
like no because you're an idiot you need
to pay attention to your surroundings it
would the same thing if you're trying to
play like a match 3 game on your phone
while walking that's probably not a good
idea don't don't do that you'll play
pokemon go longer it's different though
because Pokemon go encourages you to you
know to mix the real world it's fine
okay so it's not like a match freeware
it's a game that you're solely focused
on your screen this game asks you to
look around through your phone and
interact with the real world when you're
playing a video game so it has
culpability do you only look at the
mini-map or do you look at the are you
like someone who plays GTA like I don't
even know look at the road just hold on
a minute this whole game is a mini man
Justin you don't just stare at your
mini-map that's dangerous well there's
not Pokemon in other parts of the mouth
how will I know when I'm close to poky
stop and I need to start twirling if I'm
not looking at the map at all times see
this is what was missing from glass
physically twirling or like I don't
think that works know who would try it
afterwards if it's for science what was
missing from google glass if this had
been a part of google glass like that
would it would have been oh come on
universally accepted ya know if you'd
had pokemon like imagine having pokemon
go and your google glass you just tap it
like people would have stopped thinking
of it as douchey they would have just
been like I I need a google glass as
well I think Pokemon go I think google
glass failed for other reasons outside
i'm not having pokemon but this this
would have saved it on the eye you are a
crazy tech obsessed person meter who
weird you out more uh someone walking
around with a very small bluetooth
talking out loud like they're talking to
you or someone clearly just searching
for pokemon in a corner somewhere weird
I think the Bluetooth the Bluetooth
guide the Bluetooth guy is because he's
intruding which is okay not you to your
nerd you're not like we're not weird at
all very like pokemon alright well let's
this is I you know you're not weird and
i would like to enable both of your
behavior however there are there's a
time and there's a place and as we're
starting to see from social media
accounts from various governmental and
societal institutions and
sometimes it's not appropriate like in
the Holocaust Museum in Arlington
National Cemetery both of which have
sort of put out notices like yo please
do not be catching pokemon gold go you
know playing pokemon in our established
is it true that the World Trade Center
Memorial is also a pokey stop or a gym I
don't know is that correct it's totally
possible I there are a lot of very big
public areas that are marked is this
roving stops it marks yeah and it's it
play it encourages you to go to a place
to be nearby you don't usually have to
be you don't have to be inside of a
place to use it they use the focus top
yes like the Holocaust Museum you don't
have to be like walking right along the
Vietnam Veterans Memorial to get that
coughing and then just like yeah yeah
all right yeah I got you and even more
than a regular mobile game or using your
phone it does feel disrespectful because
it is a game that is imposed upon the
real world and I doing that in places
like that like that's also you're not
using common sense that's true showed
you difference right so yeah that's that
said i will look at all the screenshots
of a pokemon in your toilet that you
want to post that is just delightful
that's dig 'let's that's my Instagram
account yeah oh not safe for work is
Justin hey Walt Instagram account all
right let's talk about the positive side
people like ending up in parks together
I like just being as part of that sense
of camaraderie have you you know has
anyone gotten married from meeting in a
park from Pokemon go yet it's only been
seven day that would be a little bit man
Eric speaking in the people have
probably people have a probably hooked
up from Pokemon go your own I Pokemon go
I'm into Pokemon go there's a toilet
over there let's just we are two
shooters maybe there's a dick litter we
have such things we already caught all
our dig let's maybe you wanna okay just
did dig it not just some some of the
stores have been really outstanding
right so i think it was arena in our
australian office right who posted on
facebook how her in her housemates like
I think was eleven o'clock at night
there times that you know decided to go
to the local park to you know to try and
catch some pokemon and there were like
dozens of other people there and someone
had dropped the law and everyone was
cheering because someone had dropped all
the way it was so like big sort of
community sort of like
feeling towards it and yeah that there's
a lot of like positivity around this
game right now and I'm seeing a lot of
folks that you know you wouldn't
normally expect to be playing a Pokemon
game playing this game all right so it's
it's I think all the negative stuff is
but it's standing out right now because
like the mass media sort of caught on to
this right so everybody is writing stuff
about Pokemon and you know they'll pick
the most sort of dramatic angles to try
and go in at right but I think the vast
majority of stories that people have
about this game is being about you know
having fun and discovering how you know
other people are into it and how awesome
it is to you know all be in the sort of
community and being part of the
zeitgeist yeah it's something that
breaks down so many like cultural and
boundaries that that you can just be
hanging out it's it's pretty obvious
when you're playing pokemon go and use
your so many stories of someone pointing
that out saying like hey are you playing
pokemon go I just caught a growlithe or
something right over there like this
that kind of small incidental things
this bizarre guerrilla leaf or growlithe
grab probably growl aah growl if okay
but it's Li th e like I don't know a
damn thing about the petrological i well
uh you've convinced me to download it
again what I haven't I have a download I
had downloaded it but then I deleted it
cuz I didn't want sooo bad read my
emails which I think we can all agree
was a safe maneuver by no I did hear you
describe sort of the the positivity
around this and you know to see it
myself and sort of like exchange those
knowing nods i mean that's that's a way
i think that this technology in this
kind of a our game you know takes a step
towards you know maybe like creating
more social cohesion as opposed to the
ice often isolating you know influence
of technology on our lives so thanks for
sharing the stories gents to know where
and I hope all y'all share some stories
for your of your Pokemon go exploits
please share them let us on Twitter and
in gamespot comments we'd love to hear
you